ariana grande closes the one love  Manchester benefit concert surrounded by  her famous friends Katy Perry Miley  Cyrus Pharrell Williams and more  [Music]  the 23 year old singer made an emotional  return to the stage for her first  performance since the May 22nd  Manchester attack that left 22 dead and  more than 100 injured ari took the stage  solo for her final song of the night a  heart-wrenching rendition of somewhere  over the rainbow which was clearly hard  for her to get through fans in the  audience were also brought to tears all  the proceeds from the one loved concert  will go to the victims and their  families affected by the bombing at  Ariana's concert nearly two weeks ago  [Applause]  [Music]  we  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]